si vous voulez bien vous asseoir la
séance est ouverte lors du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur laurent marc
angeli merci monsieur le président le
seul premier ministre ce week end entre
deux avions
vous avez dit nous devons continuer à
réformer votre langue a fourché
vous vouliez certainement dire nous
devons commencer à réformer on allait
voir ce qu'on allait voir avec la loi
macron qui allaient à renforcer
l'économie on voit surtout un texte
composé de 405 article qui ne règle rien
et qui crée encore des taxes comme hier
soir une nouvelle taxe sur les
professions juridiques
on allait voir ce qu'on allait voir avec
la loire et cela mène une grande réforme
du dialogue social et du marché du
travail
au final rien de concret sur les seuils
pas de réformes structurelles
rien sur le contrat de travail rien sur
le code du travail
en revanche que de contraintes
supplémentaires pour les chefs
d'entreprises qui n'ont plus confiance
en la reprise économique
leurs inquiétudes elle progresse sans
cesse de six points en trois mois avec
84% d'entre eux qui se disent inquiets
face à la situation économique et même
21% très inquiet selon un dernier
sondage
et pendant ce temps là le chômage
explose 615 mille demandeurs d'emploi
depuis 2012 face à cela notre réponse
c'est plus de contrats aidés mais
toujours pas de réforme
votre réponse celle annonce dans
l'urgence de nouvelles mesures mais
toujours pas de réforme
monsieur le premier ministre ces
nouvelles mesures
c'est la panique à bord pourquoi ne
figure est elle pas dans les projets de
lois macro et rebsamen
dès le début de leur examen avez vous eu
une majorité pour faire adopter ces
mesures monsieur le premier ministre
avez vous eu une majorité pour engager
des réformes nécessaires redonner
confiance à nos entreprises avez vous
une majorité qui comme vous le prétendez
m l'entreprise monsieur kone ministre
merci la parole et à monsieur emmanuel
macron ministre de l'économie de
l'industrie et du numérique
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs député monsieur le député
les réformes ont commencé et je regrette
d'ailleurs que vous ne suffit pas lorsqu
elles permettent d'améliorer l'économie
et d'améliorer l'activité de notre pays
quand il s'agit mais non quand il s'agit
précisément de répondre à la
problématique de la compétitivité nos
entreprises
quand il s'agit du pacte de
responsabilité quand il s'agit de
moderniser le dialogue social oui ce
sont des réformes qui ont commencé et
qu'ils continueront ce matin le premier
ministre a annoncé une série de mesures
qui permettent d'aller plus loin
alors pourquoi avoir attendu parce que
il y a un temps du dialogue social et
parce que la compétitivité de ce pays
elle ne se décidera pas et c'est
peut-être ce qui nous sépare et je le
respecte
elle ne se décidera pas en réduisant les
droits des salariés
elle ne se décidera pas en affirmant des
mesures qui n'ont pas d'abord été
concertés et c'est tout le travail qui a
été commencé en février dernier par le
premier ministre quand il a reçu les
partenaires sociaux qui a conduit un
ensemble de concertation encore la
semaine dernière et à des décisions qui
ont été annoncés ce matin
tout cela se fait en bon ordre et au bon
rythme
alors ces mesures quelles sont elles eh
bien d'abord de permettre précisément de
répondre au défi des pme et des tpe sur
la commande publique de permettre de
répondre aux défis des pme et des tpe en
donnant plus de souplesse dans l'accès
aux contrats à durée déterminée par le
renouvellement en donnant plus de
souplesse pour l'apprentissage et
l'accès à l'apprentissage en accroissant
les durées ce qui était demandé par les
professionnels et vous le savez bien ce
sont aussi des mesures importantes qui
en continuant la réforme qui avait été
commencé à l'assemblée en janvier
dernier donnant plus de visibilité aux
prud'hommes ce qui répond à la
préoccupation des vrais salariés et des
vrais chefs d'entreprise et bien
d'établir un plancher et un plafond pour
donner précisément
cette visibilité à l'ensemble des
acteurs sociaux
toutes ces mesures qui ont été annoncées
ce matin c'est un paquet cohérent c'est
le small business act à la française
parce que la réforme continuer merci
monsieur nice